hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and i'm
just checking it out i'm just checking
in on you
see you nine weeks going sorry a couple
days late
yeah sorry about that i've done [ __ ]
up i know i was supposed to be here
thursday
didn't get here until saturday but hey i
still made it the same week didn't i
didn't um yes i had a uh
i had an acting gig this week and um
you know we were shooting a lot
shooting a whole bunch of [ __ ] and
shooting it in a short amount of time
one of those deals
and it was um i had a great time
i think it was the first time i ever
wasn't like counting down
you know um i usually when i get to a
set
you know because it's [ __ ] anxiety
this is not what i do i'm a comedian
right so i usually have this [ __ ]
anxiety and i look at the trailers and i
immediately get this sense of sadness
like ah [ __ ] here we go
oh no this is gonna be [ __ ] 90
million
goddamn takes 90 million [ __ ] hours
and all this [ __ ] and it was the exact
opposite
we just were moving at a rapid rapid
pace
which um i don't know if it's a comedian
thing or
i just how i'm used to working so i had
such a great time met so many great
people
and um it was fun to get back out there
and do it
you know i went to lax for the first
time
in i don't know a long long time i don't
think i'd been there since
maybe february of last year i don't even
know
um can't say i missed it
you know sometimes you break up with
somebody and then you run into them
years later you're like
you know what i think it's you want that
bad what the [ __ ] or
you have that uh or it's just like
i can't believe i was ever that
connected to that person i don't feel
anything anymore
and then there's the one that you you
run into and you're like oh yeah
oh yeah made the right decision on that
one
and that would be lax
i guess they're building a train to
get to lax it only took them [ __ ] i
don't know 60 years to figure that one
out
they're doing it because the olympics
are here and they want to make sure that
you know you always put on your best
face that the you know whenever you have
a a world event
you know which i don't even know if
that's possible anymore
a world event because there's just so
many different platforms and places to
watch [ __ ]
to try to get the eyes of everybody
watching something is uh
it's very few things very few things
like uh
maybe a presidential election when
everybody's really into it
like this last one everyone was on the
one before that
you know say what you want about old
donny boy there the guy sells tickets
[Laughter]
with that lady when he won the first
time screaming
yeah people definitely have a reaction
um
so anyway that guy should have been a
manager of wrestlers man he would have
[ __ ]
emotion that he brought up either way
would have been [ __ ]
a great addition to saturday [ __ ]
russian
wrestling saturday morning wrestling
wrestling that i used to watch but
anyway
yeah did not miss lax so they're finally
making a um
a uh a train to go there because yeah
when you have like a world event you got
to make sure everybody oh this is what
our country's like
the city's clean it moves smoothly
smoothly and everybody's in a good mood
like i remember watching that thing the
uh when we were kings
about muhammad ali fighting george
foreman the thriller in manila whatever
the hell it was
and the guy running the country there
because everyone was going to be there
watching it
rounded up every bad person he could
find and took care of him
all the criminals all the [ __ ]
pickpockets and everything i don't know
what he did to him
one of those deals he sort of suggested
that he killed a lot of them
but uh kind of makes you wonder like
well why wouldn't you do that to begin
with
if it was that [ __ ] easy
um because you know what it is because
then you got to start killing people in
the government oh
jesus christ here but you're crooks
so um yeah i don't even know what's
going on in the world
i got some texts about the bruins sabres
game i guess they had a wild one and the
[ __ ] sabers beat us so now i know if
i go on my twitter feeds people will gee
we got the best of that trade
they don't never see course you got a
good player we got a great player too so
you got
a good player in bourke who i really
liked i thought was he was really
developing this year but i get it
um we got to make a move now the bruins
have been playing great i think this is
the first time we've lost and i don't
think the sabers are going to be a
yeah i'm going to say it i don't think
you guys can be a [ __ ] problem come
playoff time
so you enjoy your regular season [ __ ]
victory
you enjoy you got this is how bad the
[ __ ] sabers has been
i brought up the [ __ ] sabers i was
giving them [ __ ] and one of the sabers
fans brought up josh allen
you know that's when it's bad when you
have to jump sports
i thought we were talking hogger here
but we're doing better in football
are you okay you made the playoffs you
won a [ __ ] playoff game we won the
[ __ ] division like
two decades in a row and won six super
bowl titles all right there you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] rooting for you buffalo
so you watch your tongue on my twitter
feed
okay you know what's gonna be funny with
global warming
what that's gonna do to buffalo and all
of a sudden it just becomes this
gorgeous you know 70 degrees all year
round
lakefront property that they had and
everybody will be flocking
is buffalo the new [ __ ] malibu
that's what's gonna happen that's how
we're gonna handle global warming
rather than actually doing something
about it in the in the final minutes
we're just all going to be you just got
you know la's on fire there's
earthquakes miami's underwater
people it's all about buffalo new york
and all you [ __ ] people in buffalo
who've
toughed out all those goddamn winners
you're gonna have some sort of [ __ ]
nickname
for the the new people that came moving
in then you're gonna be sitting there
like i can't even go to the anchor bar
anymore there's so many goddamn [ __ ]
l.a transplants is that a buffalo accent
i don't give a [ __ ]
um was it duffy's an anchor bar i don't
think i went
i went to anchor bar like the couple
times in their history they ever ran out
of wings
me and verzi uh we went to duffy's or
whatever the hell it was
we went to the one that wasn't downtown
we went to the other one they had wings
and then we went to the one downtown to
try and compare
and uh they were all out they were like
we're sorry one of the first times in
our history
we are out of wings and i said all right
whatever what are you going to do
we just [ __ ] had some and then we
went to some sabers game
and i remember i went in there and i saw
jeff dunham was playing
where the sabers played and i said god
damn it that man is successful
but i never got any [ __ ] wings
from anchor bar so i guess that's still
on you know when i relocate
when i'll phony me oh my god you guys
will hate me times too and when i move
out there because of global warming
right delay because i'm a hollywood
phony adam patriots fan
right whatever
then i and then the last i will not say
wide right the entire time i'm there
i wonder if there's a bar or anything
like that name but that's such a [ __ ]
overrated missed field goal it's a 48
yarder people act like it was a [ __ ]
chip shot
you know a guy missed it by a couple of
feet
isn't the real thing is that bill
belichick the genius of bill belichick
haunted you guys forever
came in and shut down your running gun
offense
that's what the [ __ ] happened and
everybody blamed uh
whatever his [ __ ] name is i'm not
gonna say his [ __ ] name because he's
he's he's he's living with enough [ __ ]
about that
do you think if he knew he was gonna
miss it he would have added more [ __ ]
uh
[ __ ] face bars on his helmet so his
face wouldn't just be sitting there
i bet he never walks around buffalo
wearing one of those old-school [ __ ]
winter hats with the earflaps
oh my god that's him
[Music]
oh sports it's [ __ ] amazing it's
[ __ ] amazing how you [ __ ] up once in
a big game
and for the rest of your life people
regular douchebags can give you [ __ ]
but if you work for a corporation and
you're pouring [ __ ] into the water
supply or turning our food supply into
poison nobody even knows who the [ __ ]
you are you explain me that one
um anyway
so i came home last night after uh
rapping on this acting gig that i i
really just [ __ ] i could not have had
a better time
could not had a better time um
i came home and uh speaking of streaming
services
i went and i i watched uh the pope
greenwich village which is not on
anything i had i had to like go on to
hulu
and then then sign up for some [ __ ]
cinemax [ __ ]
and cinemax remember that remember that
there was it was hbo
showtime cinemax and there was something
called the movie channel
and it was cinemax the movie channel and
hbo when i first started and then
showtime came along
then the movie channel went away and
then cinemax
said well we can't compete with these
guys let's show softcore porn and then
they became known as skinnermax
and uh and i don't want to happen after
that but you know what
cinemax rebranding themselves
i feel i watched the uh the pope of
greenwich village which i had not seen
i don't know i don't know when the last
time i saw it but i couldn't remember
how many lines
that i remember you woke her i remember
that one
tough that that mozzarella tough like
[ __ ] shoe leather
remember that one uh
ain't no tough guy go to jail some guy
ram it up your [ __ ] ass [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
i remember that one
anyway you know anybody can watch you
remember
charlie they took my thumb right um
just a really tight tight movie
uh they just get right in they establish
the characters they get right into it
the [ __ ] goes down
the fallout happens the the resolution
and you're out just a
phenomenal movie and this time when i
watched it
um you know i love everybody in the
movie but geraldine
page who plays uh the mother of a police
officer in the movie
i was watching her and i was like oh
mike who the hell is this
this woman is amazing and then i went
and i looked her up
and she was one of the great actors of
all time she had been nominated for
seven oscars and she won on her eighth
or six officers and finally won on her
seventh
so i wanted to find out what the movie
was
and i clicked on it and
it was this big thing that was talking
about how
when she was up for the oscar whoopi
goldberg was also up for the color
purple
and how the color purple was nominated
for like [ __ ] i don't know
like 72 oscars and didn't win anything
and blah blah blah the whole thing just
it just sucked you know
it just it just kind of took away the
joy of being like oh who's this great
[ __ ] actor
oh she finally won the oscar and then
it's like yeah but then they did all
this [ __ ] racist [ __ ] but
you know the thing about the oscars they
only give out one so then they always
have to give out like like
makeup oscars like oh sorry we didn't
give it to you for the color purple
here it is for ghost right not saying
she wasn't great and ghost but they're
always doing that sorry
uh we didn't give it to you for [ __ ]
raging bull
here it is for the departed they're
always they're always behind
um the whole thing is silly
the whole thing is just really [ __ ]
silly and uh i just wanted to learn
about this [ __ ] actress and then i
had to delve into the [ __ ]
horrificness
of all of that [ __ ] and uh but i'm still
gonna go back and watch
oliver films and i also still wish
whippy goldberg was still acting
i get why she isn't
it takes a a long [ __ ] time
on those gigs but uh
i don't know i don't know huge fan of
both of them though
but anyway geraldine paige i'm gonna go
she was married to riptorn did not know
that
and uh just was the real deal movies tv
broadway whatever you wanted she could
do it and
i read a little thing when she passed
away the caliber of actor that showed up
to pay their respects
was just was beyond a list it was also
like actors actors were all there so
uh i think i'm gonna go back and start
watching all of her stuff
to see why you know i don't know see all
these movies she got nominated for and
then i'll learn about more actors and
blah blah blah blah
because i'm on the road that's what i'm
doing out here missing my family
and uh but i get back today by the time
you hear this i'll already be back
and uh i can't wait to see my kids i had
like the best
face time call ever with my baby boy
um he was so excited to see me and i
just started
you know he's at that age where he's you
know making noises and stuff just going
like
doing that so i started doing that doing
all of that type of [ __ ]
and he was just dying laughing and my
wife took a screenshot of me
and i look like i don't know what like i
was on
i don't know some sort of whatever the
happiest drug is ever
which is basically making your your your
baby laugh
it's the greatest feeling ever i was
killing
i did a tight like three and a half four
minutes and i was killing
this kid was dying laughing and then
trying to reach to the phone
you know to touch my face because
obviously they don't understand the
technology at that point or maybe your
kid does
maybe you have some genius kid who
already understands this is a cell phone
google he's in another state um
and uh and then my
my daughter's been telling like knock
knock jokes just makes up knock knock
jokes
and that make no sense but are
absolutely silly and stupid
and she laughs her ass off which cracks
me up so
um yeah i can't wait to get back and
hang out with them
um yeah it's just awesome
you know i go bike riding with my kid
every day every day we ride bikes in the
driveway
and it's really cool now because she's
so good at her bike riding her bike
i just love watching she goes into the
garage she just walks up to it like
that's her ride you know
a little foot putting up a kickstand can
take off on her own
we play all these games follow the
leader and stuff i was telling you this
stuff i keep trying to get her to go
clockwise
around the circle in the driveway
because she only goes she only goes the
other way she goes counterclockwise
and now she's into that she goes she's
always like dad i don't like going the
other way
my other ways the other way is my
favorite and i'm just like all right so
whenever i do the follow the leader
thing i always go the other way
and uh i don't know maybe 30 of the time
she'll follow me she'll get it though
so uh anyway
um what else did i do i watched a little
bit of uh
this pistol pete documentary sort of
fascinated by that
and of course once you watch the
documentary it stops being about the
game and it starts to be about the
person
at which point you know they can never
just [ __ ]
be like this guy was great at basketball
and this is all the fun [ __ ] he did
you know they're always trying to go for
the award or tell the complete story so
then they got to get into the pain and
it's just like you know
i'm going to stop watching this yeah i
was watching it was all going good and
then it's just like but behind all of
that
like he lived moment for moment when the
ball would go through the hoop that was
his happiness
and it was the crowd's happiness too but
the crowd took that happiness home
but when pete walked off the court it's
like jesus christ
i'm watching this [ __ ] because i'm not
happy i don't want to get dragged down
by somebody else's depression
uh i'm gonna watch the rest of it but i
was just you know
i said it was not the kind of
documentary you want to watch by
yourself
when you're on the road missing your
family it's just you're like all right i
need to watch something like
silly um
so anyway i had to kill a day today
um yeah i had to kill a day today and uh
you know i was actually considering
going to a
uh to a museum
how hilarious is that my new sober life
here oh jesus
uh but this one actually interests me
sort of an old west
native american type of thing which i
find that
way more interesting um
than uh i don't know sometimes when you
go i'm actually i can't even say that
some of this [ __ ] my wife is into art
ah dude she's in the [ __ ] ad
look at the colors why do you think he
smeared that [ __ ] over there as opposed
to down in the corner
um but i'm actually starting to
i guess appreciate it there's a few
things that i never understood that i'm
starting to be
okay i can kind of see that one of which
is ginger baker ginger baker forever
people have said to me what an
unbelievable [ __ ] drummer that guy is
and you know i know this is sacrilegious
but i would listen
and i like cream i like all that stuff
but i never quite
got i knew they were an amazing band and
i love their music but i never
understood like what
makes this guy so much better than the
next guy right
and i remember when i watched that
documentary
beware of mr baker and when they asked
him about john bonham and he goes john
bonham couldn't swing a sack of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i almost fell out of my [ __ ] chair
when he said that because i have never
heard anybody yeah i've heard
people say you know yeah i like him but
i like this guy i like stuart copeland
and i like this guy better tony williams
you know
elvin jones like you know different guys
everybody's got their guy right but i
never heard anybody just say that he
basically stunk
and ginger baker said that and i [ __ ]
was i just
it hit me like a [ __ ] cold bucket of
water and then i just
burst it out laughing it was just so
[ __ ]
it was like watching a comic on stage go
after something that everybody's loving
and just [ __ ] all over it's just it
just the fact that you're doing it
is funny um it's like i got a couple
close friends of mine that just think
the beatles are overrated and it's just
it's [ __ ] hilarious because uh
you know they're held in such high
esteem you know i don't agree with that
at all on any level and then you know
they always go after their weaker [ __ ]
you know
maxwell's silver hammer
we all live in a yellow submarine and
they completely ignore all the other
groundbreaking [ __ ] that they did right
so i always find that [ __ ] funny so i
just sort of stumbled upon
this drum solo that uh
ginger baker did uh when cream reunited
and did that tour i cannot [ __ ]
believe i didn't see him
but they are playing at royal albert
hall
one of the most incredible venues in the
world
and uh there's a clip of him playing a
drum
solo and uh i
just sat there and i watched and he just
took me on a [ __ ]
10-minute ride that was incredible
all polyrhythms and all of this [ __ ] and
starting out with the theme and just
like just just
gradually drifting away from it to the
point that i forgot it and when he
finally comes back to it in the end it's
just like
holy [ __ ] how the [ __ ] did he go from
that
all the way all the way all the way over
to here
playing you know the jazz swing thing on
the ride
and doing this and then building that up
and doing this sick ass fill
and just stopping after that
having the crowd go nuts like he's
working the crowd too
and then he just goes back to that
first theme again and then as he's doing
that
you know clapton and jack bruce come
walking out
and then play the original theme that
they played and then they ended it was
just
it was a thing of [ __ ] beauty
so um i think that's maybe and i always
have to tell you like i never really
liked the drum
sound on a lot of those cream albums
like i just thought it could have been
way more up in the mix
i didn't think they sounded as good as
some of the other stuff that came out
during that time i don't know this is
probably sacrilegious to say that so
maybe that's why i didn't quite connect
with it
but uh yeah
i don't know so i'm gonna try to watch
some more of his
i'm gonna watch that whole concert is
what i'm gonna do
and uh so i don't know
i feel kind of stupid now
i was just like oh [ __ ] now i get it now
i get it
you know what i'm gonna have that
written on my tombstone now i get i'm
not
getting cremated [ __ ] get rid of me
um all right liquid death there's a new
brand out there that looks just like
tall boys of beer dude i stand behind
this product
more so than anything on that i read
about on
my podcast liquid death they're dealing
with
the fact that um
i mean i think i finally get the name i
finally get it
it's like liquid death why the [ __ ]
would you call bottled water liquid
death it's because they put them in
those plastic bottles
that are going to be floating in the
ocean 800 years after you're dead
after you're done drinking it um
so these guys have put the bottled water
in aluminum cans
which you can recycle can you imagine
just if we just if just our bottled
water was an aluminum cans that we and
we recycled them can you imagine
how much better that would be for the
[ __ ] planet well thank god
there's companies like this doing this
these are the kinds of people i want to
have on my podcast
um who are actually
you know this is something you need
water everybody needs water
and they're putting it in a package that
is that is recyclable
as um as opposed to a lot of the other
[ __ ] which is just like hey
here's how to buy [ __ ] you don't [ __ ]
need and you'll eventually throw it out
um all right liquid death there's a new
brand out there that looks just like
tall boys of beer
but it's actually just mountain spring
water from the alps perfect for
uh for if you want to stay hydrated and
look cool and save the environment
time for a drinking game hey pass me
that liquid death let's go
uh yeah it's kind of a cool way to
actually just be like you know
that's sitting there drinking a bottle
of water feeling like a tool
like i actually drank one on the way to
the airport and i was worried the guy
was going to think think that i was
drinking like a miller light or
something
um anyway give me that ice cold with a
give me that ice cold aluminum can with
the skull
we're getting crazy tonight drinking
water uh this water is giving me life
why do they call it liquid death because
liquid death will brutally murder your
thirst
murder and these aluminum tall boys are
infinitely recyclable so they're
bringing death
to plastic bottles all right so that's
how they work it out uh
that's right death to plastic liquid
death also donates 10
of profits to help kill plastic
pollution
forever yeah i can get behind that
there's a way to do that uh this is what
we need to do we need to go back having
[ __ ] made out of wood
and metal and we got to bring repairmen
back and you buy a tv
and they just keep [ __ ] repairing it
like they did in the old days you bought
it when you were you know
as a wedding gift you got one and then
you just kept putting a new tube in it i
know there's going to be some sort of
waste i know people like well what about
all the trees
we got to just plant them plant them and
[ __ ] i don't know what but there's
something we got to do
something has to happen so thank god
there's a company out here trying to do
something about it um
anyway try to think of something more
hardcore than that spoiler you can't
murder your thirst and kill plastic
pollution save the earth with liquid
death
it takes up to a thousand years i
thought it was 800 years for a plastic
bottle to decompose
your plastic will outlive yeah they're
finding babies now that already have
plastic
born with plastic in their bodies
because the mother is eating fish and
the fish are in the ocean
and that's where your plastic bottles
are going this is all [ __ ] real [ __ ]
man
you know do you guys want to move to
buffalo i don't want to move to buffalo
uh you'll see these cans popping up
everywhere liquid death is available at
your local
whole foods or 7-eleven i went out and i
bought some and then they were nice
enough to send me some
i got my fridge in the office stocked up
with them i love them cracking them open
i watch a game they feel like you got a
beer can you know in your hand
you're drinking water you're not [ __ ]
ruining the environment
and you're staying sober there's a bunch
of i can't say enough about it i love it
all right moving on to the next one here
all right roman you know most guys have
tried different ways to last
longer but counting down from 100
doesn't always work
especially if you're bad from uh bad
with math uh the folks at roman
and online men's health company are
changing the game with roman swipes
the secret to longer lasting sex roman
swipes are clinically
proven uh as a clinically proven way to
last longer in bed they're effective
easy to use and fast acting but don't
require prescription they're basically
some sort of topical anesthetic that
you're putting on your dick
so your dick isn't quite as sensitive so
you can [ __ ] just keep going you know
what i mean
it's like steroids for your dick you
know
you still feel like it's the first game
of the year
roman ca uh roman can ship swipes to you
in discrete unmarked packaging and each
swipe packet
is ins is small enough to hide in your
wallet whenever you need it
swipes are great they will not transfer
to your partner so you can last longer
without worrying
um they're super easy to use uh just
take
the swipes out of the packet swipe it on
let it dry and you're good to go that's
it go to get roman roman.com
and get ten dollars off your first order
of swipes plus free
two days put some free two two-day
shipping uh that's get
roman.com r-o-m-a-n
uh for your ten dollars off your first
order of swipes and free two-day
shipping
all right stamps.com let's face it
taking trips to the post office is
probably not how you want to spend your
time that's why i recommend
mailing and shipping online at
stamps.com stamps.com allows you
to mail and ship anytime anywhere right
from your computer
send letters ship packages and pay a lot
less with discounted rates from usps
ups and more you've heard me talk about
stamps.com
they've been sponsoring the show for
over nine years now and if you haven't
tried it what are you waiting for
stamps.com brings the service of the
post office and ups
right to your computer stamps.com is a
must-have for any business
uh whether you're a small office sending
out invoices an online seller shipping
out orders
or even a giant warehouse sending
thousands of packages a day stamps.com
can handle it all with ease simply use
your computer to print official us
postage
24 7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup
or drop it off it's that simple with
stamps.com you get discounts of up to 40
percent off post office rates and up to
62 percent off
ups shipping rates um stop wasting your
time go to the post office
and go to stamps.com instead i'll stop
wasting time going to the post office
and go to stamps.com instead
there's no risk with my promo code uh
and with my promo code bur
you get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale no long-term commitments
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone
at the top of the home page and type in
bur b-u-r-r that's stamps.com promo code
bur
stamps.com never go to the post office
again
all right that is it um
i was out here uh i ate pretty good when
i was out here nothing too crazy but i
had a few
of the uh delicacies where i was
shooting i had um
this place was known for uh
i guess chicken fried steaks i tried
chicken fried steak and chicken fried
chicken
i tried an indian taco
uh native american taco basically what
it was but they still call it indian
tacos
and um that was definitely filling
that definitely sticks to your ribs they
had one on set
one day and everybody's like you're out
here you got to try whenever you [ __ ]
go out to these places there's always
some [ __ ]
food that's going to give you a heart
attack like i remember still way back in
the day
being in springfield illinois i did a
gig out there
and they were someone was just like you
ever tried a horseshoe
ah you're in springfield you got to have
a horseshoe
and i was like what's a horseshoe and
it's basically it's a horseshoe-shaped
bun
and then they have three hamburger
patties with cheese
all the fixing lettuce tomato pickle
whatever you want and then they put the
fries on top of that
season those things and then they put
another horseshoe bun on top of that
you're basically having three
cheeseburgers that are all in one bun
that's [ __ ] it's like that guy fieri
[ __ ] no was he one of those no
it wasn't really his not not his show it
was more than uh
man versus food type of thing
you know and you probably have to eat
like the clydesdale horseshoe
one you know three of those or something
to get your [ __ ] name on the wall or
some [ __ ] like that
uh but anyway uh i'm psyched to be back
out here in los angeles
i'm psyched to be traveling uh as of
tomorrow sunday i am fully vaccinated
both shots
two weeks out um they say you still wear
the mask
you know freak people out or whatever
but it's just kind of nice to know that
i i [ __ ] somehow got through all this
[ __ ] and didn't catch that [ __ ] awful
virus
you don't want to get it and i just hope
you know like i said
from the people who cured polio comes
the cure and all every other disease
in plague comes this [ __ ] you know i
stand with doctors
i'm bill burr and i stand by this
message
all right so that's it everybody that's
the podcast thank you for being patient
um
i'll uh i'll tell you have a great rest
of your weekend and i will uh
i'll talk to you on monday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday april 22nd
2013 how are you
how you doing well that's good
um what a week it's amazing how much the
world can change in a week
this week had everything sadness
fear triumph
and conspiracy theory what else do you
need
and by conspiracy theory i'm of course
talking about
how the [ __ ] los angeles lakers made
it into the nba playoffs
[Laughter]
dude the nba is the most manipulated
i it's just it's almost like they're
trying to get caught
you know what i mean i'm gonna sound
like this [ __ ] guy who made this
conspiracy theory about the bombings in
boston but
you know to steal his [ __ ] line how
much more proof do you need
all you got to look at is [ __ ] who
would you rather see in the playoffs
who's going to make a more [ __ ] money
huh the [ __ ] utah
jazz of the los angeles lakers
jesus christ i mean it was it was
[ __ ] ridiculous
and now they're in the playoffs and they
suck but people are gonna watch because
they hate them just to watch them suck
and watch them get pounded it's just
just [ __ ]
i it's it's the worst it's the easiest
[ __ ] league to fix
all right nobody has more power than a
[ __ ] nba official
i could fix a game i don't even
understand the game
you know all i got to do
is just [ __ ] i've said this before
all you have to do is a [ __ ] nba ref
who's their best player
give them two quick ones
foul and then another foul
right then is he sitting there turning
around looking over his shoulder with
his [ __ ] eyebrows down
you know some guy's worth 300 million
[ __ ] more than i am in my stupid
athlete's foot shirt i just look at him
like yeah keep looking i'll give you a t
i'll [ __ ] tee you up right so now
he's out of the [ __ ] game
he comes back into the game the second
quarter i give him another one that's
three
see in the third quarter buddy
there's no other [ __ ] sport you can't
do that in nfl football
you know i can't call intentional
grounding [ __ ]
two times on tom brady and get him out
of the game until the second quarter
i can't call three strikes you know what
i'm saying
it is the most manipulat obvi and
obviously
brutally obviously manipulated game this
is what kills me
what [ __ ] kills me about the
mouth-breathing
[ __ ] morons that you walk into
that you bump into that you walk into
i'm a [ __ ] mouth breathing [ __ ] i
can't even express my views
um i'm actually taking a class on that
how to express your views
how to call other people dumb without
sounding dumb yourself
have you found yourself on your podcast
with no guests
no um this is what kills me about these
[ __ ] mouth breathing mourns if you
start telling that the nba is fixed or
it's [ __ ] manipulated they roll their
eyes at you
like you're a [ __ ] and what [ __ ]
kills me is they had a mobbed up ref
they had a [ __ ] mobbed up riff
and then they do that [ __ ] i was just
one
it was just one yeah just one bad seat
like
the nba it's boxing it's basically
boxing without it's just
as [ __ ] corrupt i love that [ __ ] how
it was just won
how there was a mobbed up ref and none
of the other referees
on the officiating crew could figure out
that this guy was throwing games or
shaving points i mean
what are they doing they don't notice
give me a [ __ ] break is all i'm
saying all right and then another thing
is i i there's no other [ __ ] sport
where the star players get the level of
preferential treatment i don't want to
hear from you [ __ ] nfl fans
with how they protect quarterbacks okay
they do that straight across the [ __ ]
league
because those guys are their bread
winners and obviously a peyton manning
brady is going to get more the star
players always get more preferential
treatment okay
in all sports i'll throw that out there
but none
none like the [ __ ] nba
all right if you go near kobe bryant
you're getting a [ __ ] foul
if it doesn't go in he looks at the ref
like it didn't go in
obviously i was fouled and he gets the
[ __ ] call it's annoying
um i haven't said all that as much as i
hate the lakers that was the [ __ ]
worst thing i've seen in sports in a
long time other than that kid's leg
falling off for louisville
was uh uh kobe uh
snap is snapping his [ __ ] achilles
but luckily they're in a in an age now
where they
he's gonna be back the way that they can
uh operate on
the like what am i trying to say the
level of technology that they had like
back in the day you were [ __ ]
it was over uh my buddy jason lawhead
who's got a great podcast
himself um was saying dominique wilkins
came
took a year off after injury and
actually came back and became nba player
of the year but he was never the same
guy but but
it's different now you know which of
course they won't take into
consideration so when he does come back
they're gonna be the most unbelievable
improbable you know ugh
isn't it ridiculous my my level of
[ __ ]
it's not even the lakers it's their
[ __ ] fans
their lack of knowledge on the game
where they have one of the most selfish
self-centered [ __ ] players of all
time
and how the team actually plays as a
team when he's not on the [ __ ] court
and they still chant
mvp when that [ __ ] cancer comes back
out on the court it just blows my
[ __ ] mind you know why
because everybody's in a fantasy league
and it's all about well he had [ __ ]
38 and this guy
had 22 therefore he's 16 points better
all right
let me take my tampon out here and uh
let's get on with the podcast you're
listening to the monday morning podcast
and it's not brought to you by anybody
this week
it's brought to you by me in my [ __ ]
heart
um all right so i started off with
something silly and over the top um
i don't i don't like talking about
heaviest [ __ ] on this podcast but
obviously i got to acknowledge what
happened at the boston marathon um
you know i'm not going to say anything
that everybody else hasn't already said
i just don't know how somebody could how
do you [ __ ] do that
just walk up and you're setting it down
and you're looking at people's legs and
kids and [ __ ] and you just walking away
knowing that and whatever
seven minutes eight minutes whatever the
[ __ ] it i mean just how do you do
something like that you know
[ __ ] unbelievable goddamn nerds man
i gotta tell you something nerds are
some of the most dangerous [ __ ]
people
on the planet okay those two were a
couple of nerds
nerds [ __ ] mit [ __ ] nerds you sent
me in a goddamn
hobby store to cannibalize some [ __ ]
toys you think i'm coming out with a
bomb
i'm not i'm coming up with the [ __ ]
ugliest toy you've ever seen in your
life
all [ __ ] taped together with duct
tape i don't know what
what is in a [ __ ] hobby store
what is in there what did they what did
they some glue
i don't know what they took um
and there's another thing that [ __ ]
annoys me you know and then everything's
nerds they make all these [ __ ] movies
like they're these great goddamn people
they aren't
they aren't all the weaponry that you
see
across the [ __ ] globe for as much as
some sociopath
thinks of the [ __ ] it takes a nerd to
make that psycho thought
of [ __ ] reality
[ __ ] goddamn nerds you teach them you
know the secrets of the world and this
is what they do with it
you know well they come up with
something and then somebody else uses
it for [ __ ] evil i don't know what
the [ __ ] thing is but here's my thing
[ __ ]
any terrorists listening to this podcast
are you are you in a [ __ ] cave right
now you know
jerking off to your [ __ ] 72 virgins
or whatever the hell they're promising
you
all right first of all they're not there
when you die you go in the ground
okay that's where you're going so what
you want to do is you want to try and
stay alive
you know meet yourself a cute [ __ ]
lady
you know have a cookout
ride a bicycle fill the wind in your
[ __ ] hair
or in your beard you know
what are you doing when is your district
manager going to go [ __ ] do something
instead of sending all you [ __ ] over
here here's another thing too
how about you switch it up every once in
a while and you go to a gated community
you know does it always have to be
regular people
why don't you actually [ __ ] go after
the [ __ ]
that are making your life miserable and
you know who i'm talking about
i'm talking about the [ __ ] bankers
you know let me tell you something about
these banker [ __ ]
they [ __ ] own everything
you understand me they own everything
and if they don't own it
it's just temporary because somebody's
gonna [ __ ] die
or need a kidney and then they're gonna
lose whatever the [ __ ] that they own
you know every [ __ ] house
every [ __ ] building every [ __ ]
piece of property every [ __ ] blade of
grass
these [ __ ] banker [ __ ] own
and they look at it that way that's our
stuff
okay and then you go on it you you air
quote
buy it from us and then we bend you over
that fence and [ __ ] you in the ass for
30 years by the time you come out the
other side
you're too [ __ ] old to take care of
whatever you bought
i can't go up the stairs anymore too old
and then you sell it and then they get
another 30 35 year old cut in there and
they [ __ ] bend him over
[ __ ] have at it for 30 goddamn years
that's what they do
yeah so i don't know what
those people were trying to [ __ ]
achieve all they did was just
you know make a bunch of regular people
just there's no way to hear whatever you
whatever your [ __ ] cause is i don't
give a [ __ ]
you could actually have agree with me on
everything that i think about the
[ __ ] world the second you walk into a
crowd and just [ __ ] do something like
that it's
i i don't want to hear it
um but you know what was what was
[ __ ] amazing
was how they just shut the whole [ __ ]
city down
i mean that's just unbelief everybody
just stay inside and then you just got
the only person running up the street is
the guy you're looking for a couple of
crackheads you know
crackheads don't have radios plus they
live outside where the [ __ ] am i
supposed to go
in my box you know
get your feet up on that park bench your
[ __ ] feet come off the park bench
you're officially considered outsider
you
could shoot two in your [ __ ] neck
there kid
how funny was the news coverage listen
to all those [ __ ] boston accents
yeah we ascertain that there's no
suspects on morrissey boulevard
um
[Laughter]
and the i actually didn't watch most of
it
once the [ __ ] was going it's like
i'm not gonna sit here for eight hours
and watch a goddamn standoff
watching these [ __ ] news reporters
grabbing anything with a mouth
to start talking to him you know
uh we got a uh we got a gentleman here
who works at uh uh
he works at edemann's bakery uh
you said that uh you you you actually
knew
one of the uh suspects actually no
but um both of them had brown hair and
uh
my mother's got brown hair so there's
like you know
it's like eerie you know
then one time they actually got a guy
who where one of the suspects dropped
off the car
you know and he had all this [ __ ]
unbelievable information
and he's just spewing it out on
television and
and they're also filming the cops where
they're at in their location i just
wanted something like [ __ ]
20-year vet to come up to one of these
reporters stick a pistol
right underneath his [ __ ] chin and
just be like whose [ __ ] side are you
what
they're sitting there showing what
they're doing
i don't know but anyways i i was
really amazed at how quickly
and efficiently that whole thing went
down and how quickly they got those guys
uh
it was unreal um
and then i was happy that when i found
out i'm sitting there going please
please don't be from north korea
please don't be from the middle [ __ ]
east please don't be from one of those
[ __ ] places
because these [ __ ] [ __ ]
are gonna beat us because if we keep
bombing every [ __ ] and going to war
with every country that they're from i
mean we're gonna go bankrupt i mean we
just spent like [ __ ] out how many
billions of dollars did we just spend
to catch like 35 people i don't know why
we just don't send the drones over there
what are they gonna do worst thing to do
is they shoot one down it gives a [ __ ]
you just make another one have a [ __ ]
nerd
make another one
and you just fly around over there right
damn i know i'm over overly simplifying
it but
um then i found out they were from
chetanya and i went chet yeah i would
[ __ ] you say it and uh how many people
were like
like me who said that from chet yeah you
can't even say it and let alone even
know where it is
i thought that was near like yugoslavia
or like uh
czechoslovakia
and today when i went to look it up
before the podcast so i wouldn't even
sound
dumber um
i just wrote in chet yet and i spelt it
so bad
oh my god i felt it so bad
that um i'm not even saying i still
can't [ __ ] say it right
um and i've heard them say it like nine
million times on the news
like my computer didn't even know what i
was
was typing in so i had to take my shot
at spell and chetya and then i would
russia after and then i was like oh
you made this um
evidently it's just north of georgia
in armenia and as urbanian
um it's basically to the right to the
north of turkey
you know
i don't [ __ ] know and you know what
the worst thing
about the bombing other than the tragic
loss of life you know and there's so
many so much other stuff like just
i would imagine people with hearing loss
lost you know vision or partial loss of
vision and just
i don't know just the psychological all
of that damage that was done
um right up there not right up there but
a distant third to death and injury
and psychological put it forth is the
fact
that i really felt that i was that in my
own little way i was starting to turn
the tide
and i was starting to turn red sox fans
against
that [ __ ] neil diamond song
but now now it's over because now
everybody's all patriotic
you know about boston they played the
[ __ ] song they played it at yankee
stadium
i'm getting douche chills just talking
about it and then neil diamond himself
the devil himself
comes to [ __ ] fenway and everybody
reaching out touching me
touching the [ __ ] joy
in these people's faces as they sing
along with this man who wrote a song
about an eight-year-old girl
i i don't understand it
but it's over now i give up i'm throwing
in the [ __ ] towel
it's it's over because now it now it is
it's
it's now associated with the triumphant
feeling of getting the two [ __ ]
that uh you know that started the whole
[ __ ] oh whatever
i'm [ __ ] this way i'm not a news
correspondent
i can't even explain it without saying
[ __ ]
who are responsible for the bombings of
boston there we go that's what i'm
trying to say and now it's associated
with that so it's it's [ __ ] over
it's [ __ ] over and um
anyways bright side
of all of this is that they got the two
guys
um and the two guys were trained in a in
a [ __ ] country that's too [ __ ] big
for us to attack at this point they got
too many too much [ __ ] themselves so
maybe we won't go
we won't have to spend a billion dollars
you know have more loss of life on our
side and have like kill a million
civilians over there trying to find
[ __ ] 35 [ __ ]
so um so i guess that part of it is good
then i love that we got him and i think
it's [ __ ] hilarious that people
there's already conspiracy theories that
that
that these aren't the two guys and it's
the youtube video of the week you got to
hear this [ __ ] guy
he basically he pieces to gather a bunch
of video and cell phone
pictures and he finds another guy with a
backpack
and and then that's it completely
ignores
you know they say innocent men don't run
yet they also don't kidnap people and
throw grenades and shoot guns at [ __ ]
police
you know that's not what you do like
wait i'm being accused by
of something i didn't do and then you
just grab a grenade out of your [ __ ]
back pocket
you know but this guy is absolutely
convinced
that from his computer he doesn't need
to go down to the scene
he doesn't need to interview anybody he
doesn't
need to be anywhere near the evidence
he just needs to be on his computer
looking at cell phone pictures
and video and so he finds another guy
with a backpack that he says
matches the one that was exploded
afterwards
and then he he goes there it is folks
he goes how much more proof do you need
then we go he goes smoked it folks game
over
he's talking [ __ ] like verzi i love the
guy when i have time i'm going to go
back to his channel i'm going to watch
all of his [ __ ] videos
because if he's going to end every
half-assed half-baked [ __ ] idea was
smoked it folks game over
i mean i don't know about you guys but
that's easily four hours of
entertainment in my world
you know anyways so here we go let's get
this is the monday morning podcast and i
am your ignorant [ __ ] host
and i'll make you feel better over the
next 60 minutes about your level of
intellect
because no matter how dumb you think you
are there's no way you're gonna come off
is it stupider than i uh
what are we up to huh how many [ __ ]
minutes is it time to do the one and
only read this week we're 20 minutes in
reaching out touching me
pedophile [ __ ] creepy old dude
get away from our damn kids
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you all right here we go i
just hate when everybody goes
bump bump bump you know ugh
oh do the world a favor and kill
yourself
kill that song um
wait a minute where the [ __ ] is where
the [ __ ] is the uh the ads for this week
everybody i did my little due diligence
here
downloads there it is stamps.com
everybody
stamps.com you know the drill
small businesses know from experience
that going to the post office is a waste
of time
but at least and but leasing an
expensive postage meter is out of the
question
i know a better way and i've been
telling you about this for over a year
stamps.com uh stamps.com will save you
valuable time you get 24 7
access to all services of the post
office right from your desk
whether you're sending envelopes or
packages first class a priority
domestic or an international however you
want to send it
get the postage you need using your own
computer printer and stamps.com you
stand standing there in your underwear
at two in the morning
and you can get all your mailing done
you can get a jump on your day
you never have to leave your house it's
fantastic it's the howard hughes
um style post office you can sit there
grow your nails in your hair you can
have a great time it's quick it's easy
and it's really convenient and you'll
never have to go to the post office
again
i use stamps.com to send out all my dvds
i don't have any problems
it's tremendous and i'm a [ __ ] and i
can figure out how to use it
right now use my last name burr burr for
this special offer
no risk trial plus a 110 dollar bonus
offer
includes a digital scale and up to 55
dollars in free postage
um don't wait go to stamps.com before
you do anything else click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in bur
burr that stamps.com enter bur
there you go that right there ladies and
gentlemen
is all the advertising for this week so
all you whiny [ __ ] out there who want
your free [ __ ] and i love how the
whiny [ __ ] want free [ __ ] and they want
no advertising
work for me for nothing um
all right before i get on to some of the
other [ __ ] that i want to talk about i'm
going to read this first uh email that i
got from somebody
and it's titled anger not hitting said
dear bill
i watched two of your specials recently
on netflix
uh while you you are a very funny guy
now this is when you know some criticism
is coming your way anytime something now
you know yeah i'm not saying you're not
a good guy
while you are a very funny guy and most
of most of the stuff is great
i really need to point out your bit
about violence against women has a major
flaw
well thank you person who never did
stand up please by all means help me fix
my jokes
there's no doubt there are plenty of
reasons a man could be
angry with the woman so there is a
reason for that
but there really is no reason and no
excuse for hitting
my ex nearly murdered me because i
didn't want
to be with him anymore and told him he
needed to move out of
my house i paid for entirely mine alone
i never laid a hand on him nor even
thought of it i spent a week in
intensive care
so you can see how i might think that
you could amend that bit
to say there are reasons for anger not
hitting
all right now for those of you who
aren't stand-up comedians
this right here is a reoccurring email
that will go on throughout your entire
[ __ ] career
and this is what i find first of all
at no point did i say anybody should hit
a woman
i never said that i said when they say
there's no reason to hit a woman i
presented scenario i just said look
there's plenty of reasons to do it you
just don't do it
that was the joke repeat the joke
capital j dash oak
joke this is what i find about people
who get
offended and she was cool or whatever
obviously you know
um this is what i find
about people who send me emails like
this
all right obese people get offended by
jokes about obesity
you know women who've been [ __ ]
beaten by some piece of [ __ ] guy get
offended about the hit and women joke
all right [ __ ] it i don't know people
who fly
pilots get offended by my [ __ ] about
talking [ __ ] about pilots but this is
what i find
pilots never get offended by the obese
material
obese people never get offended by the
hitting women thing and the dog lovers
who get offended by the dog the adopted
dog rescue dog bit
never get offended by these starving
child jokes
see what i'm saying well i understand if
you don't
let me try to explain a little better
i'm just saying
this [ __ ] lady sat through
two of my specials so the first special
okay she watches i don't [ __ ] talk
about hitting women so that's an hour
right there she sat through
laughed her [ __ ] tits off had a great
time and then she sits through about 40
45 minutes of the next one
and everything's [ __ ] fine and
everything's funny and everything's just
a joke as i'm just going through
one topic after another that's offending
the [ __ ] out of everybody who's in that
group
and then it comes around to some [ __ ]
that's in her neighborhood and then all
of a sudden i have to start making like
amends to bits
i need to tweak it a little bit because
of her [ __ ] personal experience
i have to tweak it because of her
personal experience and then all of a
sudden
what i'm saying is not a joke anymore
it's more of a statement
and i'm more more like you know i mean
earlier in this podcast i advocated
these terrorists go into a [ __ ]
gated community do you think i really
want them to do that yeah
no i don't i don't but uh just maybe
light some firecrackers off underneath
their limo just something
some sort of small payback
how easy would it be for them to get in
the [ __ ] those gated communities
they're already driving the town cars
dude if i was a banker and i was a piece
of [ __ ] banker i would be so [ __ ]
paranoid
that someone was going to whack me for
all the misery and suffering
that i [ __ ] you know that i've been
causing
the fact that i turn a [ __ ] pond into
my own jacuzzi
right i can park my yacht in my [ __ ]
jacuzzi
and i just sit there you know eating
[ __ ] crab legs and caviar every
[ __ ] day
standing on [ __ ] dead babies heads
there's no [ __ ] way i would ever get
in a [ __ ] town car there's no way
there's no way
i would have whoever my fredo
of my litter of kids whoever the fredo
was that was to be the guy that i had
driving the car
although in the godfather he was looking
out for marlon brando and then i he got
shot right so
i don't [ __ ] know anyways
oh you know i read some actually some
really interesting [ __ ]
about how iceland beat the bankers when
iceland went bankrupt
and then the bankers tried to pull this
[ __ ] where yeah we were greedy cuts and
now we're putting the debt on you
and your taxpayers they said you know
what
[ __ ] you this isn't our debt this is our
mess
it's yours and then all these [ __ ]
sellout [ __ ] like [ __ ] amsterdam and
britain put all this pressure
on [ __ ] iceland because they pussied
out with the bankers
they've been on their knees sucking that
banker [ __ ] for [ __ ] ever
they tried to [ __ ] get them to come
along they tried to pressure them and i
oh you know or else we'll turn you into
the cuba of the north
and they said [ __ ] you we're not doing
it
and you know what that's what this
country should have done
this country should have told those
banker [ __ ] [ __ ] i
i i just i'm beside myself that it isn't
brought up more
you know it's the whole thing like i
have water damage to my house
my insurance company sends a check
that's made out to me
uh nia and and then my mortgage company
and i have to we have to sign the check
over to them
so they keep the money and you know why
that is
because they [ __ ] so many people so
[ __ ] hard
in the ass so many people are upside
down in houses because of the [ __ ]
that they created
by making people who aren't qualified
for loans qualified
so instead of having five people bid on
a house you got 10 people bidding on it
and it goes up like super bowl tickets
right and all of a sudden a house that's
really worth a buck 80 sells for 270 so
you got these [ __ ]
everybody's [ __ ] upside down in the
house they're like well [ __ ] i'm
keeping this money
and then when they foreclose on it they
[ __ ] come in and they're like [ __ ]
they never fix the roof
so now i have to sign over my god their
money it's my money
it's my insurance that's my insurance
money i have to
send it in to them you know why because
people it's not my house
it's their [ __ ] house it's theirs
all right and if i ever pay this [ __ ]
off which you know i'm gonna
i drive off i drive a six-year-old
hybrid all right i don't give a [ __ ]
i i [ __ ] i dress like malcolm young
because i'm getting these [ __ ] out of
my life and this is what's gonna happen
i'm gonna pay off this [ __ ] house
and you think when i die i can i can
just give it to somebody else
it's my house right if i i can [ __ ]
give away all my other [ __ ] why can't i
give the house the house is gonna have
all
taxes and all these penalties and all
this [ __ ] and whoever i [ __ ]
leave it to is gonna be like you know
what
it's just gonna be easier to sell it and
then they sell it and whatever money
they make they get the [ __ ] taxed out of
them they get half a dick in their ass
and then somebody else buys this thing
and then that the bank goes balls deep
in them for another [ __ ] 30 years
you know what halfway through that i
realized am i sounding crazy or am i
making sense
i don't know i talked to a banker in a
titty bar he agreed with everything i
said
all right special thanks this week to uh
everybody i did uh
at the tampa who came out to the tampa
improv who came out to florida state
university
in tallahassee i'd never been there and
now came out to miami the fillmore
jackie gleason theater um
had a great time in all cities that was
the end of the bus tour when it was just
me and verzi
uh jason lawhead and his dad had gone
home at that point so it was just us on
the bus
um i gotta i have a [ __ ] unbelievable
video of being on the bus
and uh this [ __ ]
rv is is just completely engulfed in
flames
so that'll be a video that i'll be
sending out to you guys this week if you
want to check it out
tallahassee florida we played florida
state we went over to their uh bobby
bowden we went over to the uh
the stadium did i tell you that last
week
i can't remember no i wouldn't because
that would have been on a tuesday
yeah so we [ __ ] uh we was one of
these great stadiums where
it they just leave it open and the
students can go in there
and run the stairs and just
you know it's kind of how like it used
to be stadiums
even pro stadiums used to be like that i
remember a long time ago
my family was was uh vacationing down in
florida
and we we uh were in tampa
and somehow we ended up the original
tampa bay buccaneer stadiums
like the john mckay one right and i just
i wanted to see it so i got out of the
car with my mother
and we just walked right into the
stadium and i stood on the corner of one
of the end zones it was just it was wide
open
i mean what are you going to steal it's
grass chairs it's just a big [ __ ]
circle with with uh with chairs but now
i guess because they got all this other
crap in there with the luxury boxes
people think you're gonna i don't know
steal what a [ __ ] recliner
i don't know whatever so florida state
university we went there and me and
mercy actually we ran up the stairs
once one time and um
it was one of the great workouts i've
ever had just doing it once
of course me i [ __ ] ocd is like oh
you know what i do one for three days in
a row then i do two and i [ __ ] work
my way up i
just my brain just starts [ __ ] going
but um
great crowds there great crowds in tampa
smoked some amazing [ __ ] cigars
in tampa and then we went down to the
fillmore um
miami uh south beach and south beach is
so [ __ ] beautiful with uh they have
all
like i'm a big fan of art deco and they
have all these uh
art deco style hotels and uh the theater
itself
um was that art deco style the crowd was
amazing
um i'm like a lot of dude that tour i
just went through
through the south i was on my [ __ ]
game i had some of the best shows i've
ever had
and um i think it was because it took me
so long to sell tickets
down in the south like um
like the first place i sold tickets
obviously was east coast that's where
i'm from
um you know my hbo special came out
and then i got on the op and anthony
show at the same time because norton was
doing
um lucky louie so those two things kind
of hit at the same time and once they
hit
i kind of was able to sell tickets from
boston down
to like dc which is a big o
a market and um and maybe to about
cleveland but i didn't have pittsburgh
though
um and then i think i had like san
francisco that's what i had and then
gradually i got the middle of the
country
and the last one to fall was the south i
just couldn't get in down there
from [ __ ] nashville all the way down
even to like miami miami i'm going to do
the improv they're like yeah you know
white comics don't sell well down here
it's a really big latino community and
and they weren't lying i showed up there
was nobody there so i think i was
[ __ ] excited and felt like i had
something to prove
i don't know what but it was kind of
like the first show went well
and uh it's like you hit your first jump
shot you know and then it just it just
was [ __ ] amazing man just amazing so
i really want to thank everybody who
came out to all those shows
one one thing that did bum me out though
was
you know i'm a huge jackie gleason fan i
used to watch his uh
obviously watched all the honeymooners
episode and then i used to watch his uh
his uh variety show which i also loved
you know joe the bartender um
what was it crazy crazy i can't remember
it's been so long
i forget that's when i say lou holt
sounds like hey
joe hey you mickey dunny he that guy
remember that
he sounds just like lou holtz yeah you
praise freaking to you coaches
um
excuse me um
oh [ __ ] me god damn it
i swear to [ __ ] christ are you guys
like me ah
[ __ ] i spill a [ __ ] glass of water
every goddamn day
went right on my rolling stone which i
have a subscription to
[ __ ] louis ck's on the cover you know
this is one i'm obviously gonna say not
gonna [ __ ] wet now i gotta go down to
the newsstand and buy another one
but you know what that'll be good for
him because he'll think oh well
everybody's buying it because he's on
the cover they won't realize it's a
bunch of morons spilling glasses of
water on it
uh by the way if you get a chance [ __ ]
an unreal article on uh
louis ck [ __ ] killer article
killer article um
so anyways going back to uh the jackie
gleason theater so i i performed there
and then i leave and after i left
somebody goes like yeah how amazing is
that theater you know i was insane
again jackie gleason performed there and
blah blah i know i know they go did you
see his dressing room
and i was like what they go yeah
upstairs they have his dressing room
they kept it pretty much like the way he
had it after he was finally here i mean
it's amazing it's like walking back in
time
and i was like i was like what the [ __ ]
why didn't you tell me
how do i know i'll ever be back there
again
that was the only bad part but then it
was quickly made up
because versi at the end of the show
is uh he met this chef out of new
hampshire
uh tim andreola and he had this um
he was like i guess he has three
restaurants down there
celebrity chef long story short he
invites us out
keeps the restaurant open and we
basically
to use verzi's expression we dined like
gods
it was insane now forgive me tim because
i don't [ __ ] remember the name of the
restaurant
and and so you don't think i'm being
disrespectful i don't know remember the
names of any restaurants
all right like i have i just have
nicknames
for all the ones that we go to out here
one of them is called pancake circus
that's because i walked in there the
first time i saw it had this giant like
manhole-sized pancake with a bunch of
[ __ ] whipped cream on it and all i
could think of was like
that looks like clown food so i i
don't know i'm a [ __ ] but i think it's
teemo but this is the thing the first
thing we go there
the first thing they bring out is crab
legs i [ __ ] hate crab legs
i've never been into them it's so much
goddamn work to get a mouth full of
[ __ ] meat
and then it just tastes like the goddamn
ocean all right
i have been converted these [ __ ] crab
legs
not only were the best crab legs i ever
ate they were some of it was some of the
best
food i've ever had even the melted
butter tasted better than anybody else's
melted butter
i was sitting there i look like a
[ __ ]
i look like a toddler eating birthday
cake except
cake all over my face it was just
[ __ ] crab legs and
butter i must have ate like [ __ ]
three or four of those legs then he
brought over pizzas
who does pizza well in [ __ ] outside of
new york and the [ __ ] east coast this
guy
tim andreola [ __ ] pizzas unbelievable
unbelievable
and then uh we had uh is it ceviche is
that how you [ __ ]
chatting yeah i don't know how to
[ __ ] say it um
un [ __ ] believable food in the
restaurant
it's spelt t-i-m-o i know i'm saying it
wrong because there's a little fancy
accent thing over the oh tina
i don't know how to say it but it's
right on the beach all right
if you ever go down to south breach and
you bring your [ __ ] lady
then i can't say it t-i-m-m-o what the
[ __ ] is not the motley crue two dots
it's one of those little accent things
um so thank you to tim his whole staff
everybody was was insane and we came
over there was like it was like
eight of us um
and you know i swear to god they would
have still bring it we've been bringing
out food
if we didn't if we didn't uh if we
didn't leave it was one of the greatest
i've ever been uh
treated on the road and uh
you know yeah i don't know it was
[ __ ] insane
um so
what else what else am i going to talk
about i don't have any
smooth transition from that
to the next thing here i've been
watching a bunch of [ __ ] on uh
on netflix i'm big on the uh i like
documentaries
you know and i watched one and a half
last night before i fell asleep
i watched this thing called the queen of
versailles
which you have to you have to see and
it's basically about
this guy 75 years old 75 years old he
married miss florida 1993 so he's
[ __ ] balling
has seven kids with her right and he's
got this
he sells time shares you know
which you know is really a shady [ __ ]
business
you know hey i don't i mean i don't i
don't know what is it [ __ ] timeshare
it's it's it's a [ __ ] overpriced
hotel room isn't it
i mean i i don't know what am i buying
if i spend all that money i don't be
laying in a bed that somebody else has
been [ __ ] in i want a brand new bed
okay
that's that's deal number one because
other than that i can go lay in a bed
that everybody else [ __ ] in
all year long it's called the hotel
right but this guy
had basically had was the biggest time
share company
um in the world according to him
and uh and he was in the middle of
building the biggest house in america
and it had ten kitchens
this [ __ ] nine people in their family
they have one more kitchen and they have
people in their family
all right you have to watch just to see
them i mean it's not finished yet
because in 2008 they got caught up on
all the bankers [ __ ]
and um but you just have to see when his
wife walks in with her friend
and when they walk up these stairs i'm
telling you these [ __ ] stairs are
are wider than the stairs at grand
central station in new york city
they go upstairs and the the [ __ ]
friend of the miss
miss 1993 florida goes is like you know
because they haven't like put the walls
up it's just the uh the framing of it
she goes oh my god she goes is that your
bedroom
and she goes no it's my closet
but if you really want to see okay now a
lot of people will watch
the queen of versailles and go look at
these two selfish [ __ ] people and all
the waste and all that
apps are [ __ ] luffy lutely that's on
the [ __ ] surface
but underneath all of it you you see a
guy
who doesn't want to declare bankruptcy
and put that money on the american
people wants to fight his way out of it
and the bankers won't do it like he had
a building out in [ __ ] vegas
he he put 350 million of his own [ __ ]
money in
and now he can't make the payments so
he wants the bankers to try and you know
give him some of the bailout money and
they kept
all of it because this is the thing if
he [ __ ] if they get him to default on
that
they get to keep his 350 million and
sell the [ __ ] building all over again
um you know and obviously this guy he
got overextended he made the mistake
of not realizing you know
what bankers are and what it is that
they do they're not your friends
they're not trying to help you grow your
[ __ ] business they're trying to make
every [ __ ] dime
off you as they can and when it's over
you bust the joint out
i just started thinking about the the
[ __ ] uh good fellas well they start
burning it down but rather than burning
the place down they [ __ ]
did you that ray leota and [ __ ] joe
pesci are [ __ ] tying those little
candle things to you
trying to bang this [ __ ] juke rod
over here you can't help me out it's the
world coming to
um and then you you burn to the ground
that's it but the building's still
standing and then they get some other
group to go in there and then they [ __ ]
them in the ass
i'm telling you we should all as
civilians remember the ending of
scarface when they were coming over the
wall
that's what we should be doing right now
in gated communities going to bankers
[ __ ] houses
we should be dragging them dragging them
out by the tassels of their [ __ ]
wingtips
um all right anyways
so i watched that phenomenal and it was
sad it was also sad
because you saw a guy that was really
into his business but granted i think
also you know you have to find a through
line when you're filming something
because i think they initially started
the documentary
and i think initially was going to be
look how successful this guy is and then
that [ __ ] happened and then
it turned into something else so i heard
he sued the makers of the documentary
but uh
phenomenal and the music is incredible
um all right and then i watched another
one about the the serial killer
carl panzram the spirit of hatred and
vengeance you gotta [ __ ] see this
um he he writes a this guard befriends
him
and he writes a [ __ ] book in jail
and uh i forget how off i [ __ ] it i
had it in my head how he said it they
have the voiceover actor going
my name is carl page for him i have
killed over 22 people
and committed over a thousand acts of
sodomy
that's how his book starts i gotta buy
the [ __ ] book
um let me let me look this up i'll read
you a little bit about this guy in
wikipedia for some reason like
you know a bunch of other people ted
bundy speaking of florida state
dude you know florida state where ted
bundy killed those three
sorority girls um they still use that
house as a sorority house that just
[ __ ] blew me away
[ __ ] blew me away like how how in
god's name
now i'm not into ghosts i don't believe
in that [ __ ]
but uh i i i do draw a line
[Laughter]
i i don't think that i i could sleep
in that [ __ ] house knowing that all
that [ __ ]
like happened all right here we go let's
just read
carl pan's ram here um it was an
american serial killer rapist arsonist
and burglar
um here we go he's known for his
confessions to his only friend prison
guard henry lesser
let's get this this killing spree
[Music]
hmm
what the [ __ ] is it he basically he used
to have he had a boat
and he would get sailors drunk and he
would bring these guys back to the boat
he'd [ __ ] sodomize him and then shoot
him in the head and throw him overboard
one of the most evil [ __ ] things that
was basically that happened when he was
a kid
he got [ __ ] raped and then he was
like all right
well i'm [ __ ] raping everybody else i
mean the guy was just [ __ ]
yeah let me look up some quotes i don't
want to creep you guys out this would be
turn into a creepy podcast but i just
never heard of this guy
um carl prizm
what the [ __ ] is it
all right there's some website the 11
most badass words ever uttered
i hate when i do this to you guys when i
just start surfing the [ __ ] net
all right
hurry up you hoosier bastard i could
kill 10 men while you're fooling around
i don't know you know it kind of helps
if you have the context
oh i was that when they went to kill him
everyone hopes to leave a legacy to be
remembered after our passing
did it put up some people try to pull
off immortality with a lifetime of
achievement and noble acts
but why piss away all that energy when
you can simply spout one badass quote
before you take a dirt nap and live on
through eternity
known as a guy who needed a second
casket for his balls
the last words of carl pan's ramp when
they were
he said hurry up you who's your bastard
i could kill ten men while you're
fooling around
um who's just somebody from indiana
um carl panzram did make an interesting
point
about the meijer of bureaucracy versus
individual enterprise if you guys are
executing
oh but yeah basically thought they were
taking too long
wow this is great man this is all
people's last words last words of chief
sinning bull
i'm not going do with me what you like
i'm not going
then exclamation point come on come on
take action let's go
i guess that was back uh you want to
[ __ ] do this let's do this that was
that's how they said it
in the 1800s and he's also speaking a
second language that's how much balls he
had
he still sounded tough in another
language um
another guy before he got hanged the
last words of george ingall
union activist and founder of the
socialist labor party
he's standing with the [ __ ] rope
around his neck he said hooray for
anarchy
this is the happiest moment of my life
all right yeah i gotta read them all now
just when you thought you had a [ __ ]
pair here we go
gill's corey last words of a farmer
accused
of being a witch while being crushed
with stones
he said more weight
ah james french convicted word murderer
putting to death um in the electorate
chair
oh his name is james french he goes hey
fellas how about this for a headline for
tomorrow's paper
french fries i'm sorry
i'm enjoying this i hope you are too
uh last words of uh the hipster hero
how do you say his name che guevara
and the one everybody has on the t-shirt
i don't know what he did he was friends
with [ __ ] the bearded bastard down
there and then all of a sudden he went
down
he was going to play baseball all those
cuban rebels at some point they were
going to play baseball they [ __ ]
loved the game
i believe what's his face uh castro
pitched
in the farm league of the cult 45s
um all right this is what this was it
che guevara his last words were i know
you're going to kill me
shoot you're only going to kill a man
jesus i hope that they don't have
if i'm going out like that they better
not have my last words because i'm going
to sound like the biggest [ __ ] ever
come on don't do it i'm sorry
you know i was just thinking it was
what's his face uh i can't remember
anybody's [ __ ] names
i gotta get this one right
i gotta get this name right or i'll
fight i can't do this
ah [ __ ] i just it's i i i'm a [ __ ]
but let's go back to the podcast i was
thinking of uh
who's the guy who plays mcgruber will uh
there's too many wills well farrell will
learn that
it's not that it's [ __ ] i'm the worst
how he would always do that thing when
he would get into a gym and just be like
i will
suck your dick
i would have some awful [ __ ] quote
like that
i would i don't want to die don't kill
me
please do not kill me all right here we
go some [ __ ] um
i gotta look i'm gonna look up his
[ __ ] name okay addicted to who was
um hey bill love the podcast i could use
a bit of advice i'm a 30 year old man
and have a bit of a problem
over the past few years i've become
addicted to horse not just typical bar
[ __ ]
but full-blown professionals oh geez
um it's gotten so bad that i researched
the girls that i see
and the majority of my time consists of
going through message boards and
underground communities
filled with other pervs like myself who
review
working girls all right dude you're
going down a dark [ __ ] hole
i fortunately never went out
uh i'm already in over my head here
but you know whatever you wrote in so
i'm gonna [ __ ] try and answer it
knowing full well that i am not a
professional sir
he says my problem is that i have become
so
addicted to this lifestyle that i cannot
see myself having a traditional
relationship with the woman yeah
absolutely
absolutely you open pandora's box you
know
dude you you have a woman who will do
whatever you want
and you don't have to be emotionally
there for you don't have to wipe your
feet off you can just you know talk to
her wherever you want
give her some money and then she leaves
you don't have to cuddle
you have zero emotional responsibility
you know that's like somebody rich who's
been [ __ ] flying around in their own
jet
and then all of a sudden you know their
[ __ ] goes down like in that that queen
of versailles and all of a sudden they
have to get on a commercial flight
and their kids are looking around going
why are all these people on a plane
you're in the same place your dick is
like a billionaire
you know and if you get into a [ __ ]
relationship with that this point that's
like the 2008
uh collapse you know that make any sense
all right after experiencing this
lifestyle for so long i just cannot
force myself to sit at a bar
trying to convince some chick whose best
years are behind her
to give me a half-hearted bj um i
consider myself a decent looking guy
i think you consider yourself a lot more
than that sir
i think you stand in front of the mirror
with your hands on your sides
like superman not hands on your hips
hands on your hips
that's effeminate but if you stand there
with your two fists
like that then all of a sudden you look
like you should have a cape flapping
behind you
um i think you do that you stand there
and you naked
you know with like the same distance
between your feet that a state trooper
has when he comes up going do you know
how fast you were going
and then you look to the side with your
dick flapping in the wing because of the
oscillating fan
and then every morning just go i am the
[ __ ]
[Music]
um that's how i think you feel about
yourself that i would just guess
um anyways i think i'm a decent looking
guy and i do get attention from the
women
but i often find that they are not worth
the effort because i get bored so
quickly
yeah i know actually having to confer
rather than just being like hey how much
for you to suck my dick
oh yeah i'll give you half that come on
work with me me
i'll meet you in the middle i'll give
you an extra five because it's cold out
all right get in the car um my problem
is that i get bored with women
immediately after i sleep with them
i do not fear diseases as i always use
condoms
dude that's not 100 by the way i don't
know why but it is i don't know how you
can have a raincoat on your dick and
still get herpes i think cause your
balls are [ __ ] hanging out of the
back of the chopper
you know
and safety i always use condoms and
safety
and safety wise i love when you guys
like rewrite your
your [ __ ] emails and then you delete
half a sentence
and then you [ __ ] don't notice and
then you put it in here and you make me
look even dumber than i am
anyways i guess he uses condoms he said
it would be it would be just as
dangerous sleeping with a random bar
[ __ ] who doesn't force their partners to
use
condoms uh no it wouldn't sir no it
wouldn't because it's a numbers thing
all right some bar [ __ ] who doesn't use
condoms
versus some woman who [ __ ]
professionally okay that's like you
throwing the football around in the
backyard saying you're just like tom
brady okay it's
it's not the same thing but i know
you're saying that to make yourself feel
but feel better
he said i fear never being able to have
a normal relationship with the woman
down the road
i feel like my internal wiring got
crossed somewhere and i need a wide
variety of women
to keep me sane i really want to [ __ ]
every woman i see but unfortunately i
can
cannot swing a golf club so i got to pay
for it
any way out of this love the podcast
yeah you need to go to therapy
um i got to tell you though once you
once you i don't know you you need to go
seek professional help sir
i would i would i would say that because
uh
you've gone down a road for so long and
you keep coming around the track the
same way you've worn this grooving
and it's very hard to get out of and uh
you have to sit down and want to do the
work and you you have to work with
professional
and figure out if you have a sex
addiction addiction
or whatever one of the dr drew
you know if you can't afford it i would
call dr drew but even then he's only
going to talk to you for a minute
have him guide you in the right
direction though uh
because that guy is is he kind of he
gets right to it
i've done his show a couple times he's
[ __ ] unreal
um so that would be my suggestion i
would say
first and foremost stop [ __ ]
prostitutes because you are going to
catch something
and every and not only that every
everyone that you bang
or have blow you or whatever it's just
another step
further down a direction you don't want
to go
and then also it's a terrible thing to
do
you know to solicit a prostitute you
basically
you know something horrible happened to
her and then you're taking advantage of
it it's
[ __ ] horrific um
so there you go i hope i helped you i
know i gave you a lot of [ __ ] throughout
that but i hope it helps you out because
that is a serious problem
okay new house dearest billy boy
keeping it short and sweet due to your
undying hatred for reading out loud
i actually don't mind it i just i hate
sounding stupid
uh my fiance and i are moving into our
first
house on friday any last minute advice
yes um
well it's too late you already bought a
[ __ ] house
my first thing would be drive less of a
car
wear less clothes everything
less and start knocking out the
principle
all right you got to start knocking that
[ __ ] thing down
um and when they then once you knock it
down
to a certain point then they're going to
come at you and be like hey do you want
to refinance you want to refinance look
your mortgage payment will go from 1500
down to 1200 that will save you 300
bucks a month that's all a [ __ ] scam
okay do you really think there's
somebody who works at the bank in his
job
and he's sitting there going how can
this bank make less money
oh i know what i mean how long would
that guy work there before i get fired
it's a scam
because what happens is if you're like
four or five years into your mortgage
they're gonna refinance it
and your payment doesn't go down 300
bucks and you're still
five years in it starts back at zero
all right now you have that payment for
30 years and you're starting all [ __ ]
over again
so the 300 bucks that you're saving each
month they're making more in the [ __ ]
interest in the long run because they
sent you back to square one
it's all a [ __ ] scam i'm telling you
go to the gated communities and go over
the [ __ ] wall
um don't really do that all right i
don't want to be held responsible for
that
um these are all jokes wink wink nudge
nudge
um all right any other advice yeah
don't let your [ __ ] lady let let your
woman
have the [ __ ] dining room let her
have
the [ __ ] uh living room all right
but you you have to stake your [ __ ]
claim in there
don't let her turn it into a [ __ ]
dollhouse the same way she wouldn't want
to be living
in some [ __ ] you know house that
looks like a sports bar
you know and you got some [ __ ] deer
head and a keg on tap and all that [ __ ]
you know what i mean
but i just like i i would say stake your
[ __ ] claim
in the house and just say listen i want
this house to be a representative
representation of both of us all right
and uh if it goes too far one way or the
other i don't think the other person is
going to be happy
and just say listen i don't care what
you do with this i don't care what you
do with this room
just pick yourself a room or two because
this sort of unwritten rule
is that the guy gets one room and it's
the darkest
caviest [ __ ] place it's the basement
it's the [ __ ] garage
and uh it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
okay so that's what i would say
make sure that when people walk in they
can immediately see that you live there
too
that something with a set of balls is
actually in that [ __ ] house
all right and that's it good luck with
your marriage and your new house
congratulations pay down the [ __ ]
principal sir
get the shackles off you all right crazy
ass mom
hey oh there bill what's up
my name is hector i'm from i'm a
full-time college student my life is
fairly well i get good grades and [ __ ]
big family 107 by refinance with some
new pudding
started back to square one um when was i
when i was little she was basically
trying to steal me from my father and
taking all of his money in the process
he'll have no fury sir also she used to
beat me like a redheaded stepchild
i find that offensive all right you want
my advice don't insult me
all right hector
you know what i almost got childish and
made and made some joke
about your chain steering wheel because
your name is hetero but then i realized
that that would insult other mexicans
and i'm not like you sir
i'm gonna i'm gonna take the high road
here
and just say that i wish you had chosen
your words a little more carefully
all right and uh tell me okay beat me
like a redheaded stepchild
and tell tell me my dad did not love me
so i would stop asking for him wow
yeah that's uh that's something that
parents do during divorce
on both sides they use the kids that's
i'm so glad that never happened to me
and i got [ __ ] up in other ways uh
this [ __ ] left my father
with so little money that he had no
money to pay the light bill
and other [ __ ] my mom's stupid-ass
brother held a gun up to my father's
head and said he would blow his head off
because he got my mom pregnant with me
my mother's dad was also um
an ultra [ __ ] yeah so he was familiar
with [ __ ] and he went out and married
it
hopefully he [ __ ]
corrected the problem jesus you're
giving me the whole family tree here sir
um since then she had gotten remarried
and then divorced
a [ __ ] gun he says the problem is
after all that [ __ ] i can't stand to
even look at my mom
how do i tell her to basically [ __ ] off
this [ __ ] podcast is the [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't stop you red-headed maniac all
right there you made it up with
something positive towards redheads
thanks for your important no yeah go
[ __ ] yourself um
look this is very touchy because you
know as much as you consider your
biological mother your mother this
is your mother so um i don't know how
that works because i've never been in
this situation
so i wouldn't tell you your first mother
to [ __ ] off
what i would do is i would
have um
she is your mom so i would i would have
a just a very controlled relationship
with her
like i would meet her at restaurants i'd
meet her in public
and uh have lunch with her be okay i
gotta get on with my week and that way
you know
that way so when she dies someday you
don't have this regret that you know
i hated my own mother what does it mean
um
and then i would just do happy mom [ __ ]
with with your non-biological mother
you know just smile and wave go through
the motions with her but um
i don't know i'd say maybe therapy
call you call your mom a [ __ ] in therapy
rather than to her face because it's
it's not going to get you anywhere
and as you get older and she gets older
it's just it's not going to be a good
[ __ ] thing but i i totally
have empathy for the situation that
you're in i would just treat my
biological mother as my real mother
and i would have a respectful
relationship
with my uh my original mother and uh
when she started talking crazy and
everything
just be like listen you know you said
that stuff to me when i was a kid
it caused a lot of damage to me and um i
don't want to hear you trash my dad
anymore
i respect how you feel about him but i
don't want to hear about it because you
have to understand that that's my father
all right and if she has a problem with
that you just go check please
there you go she wants to make a scene
and throw some bread around then uh then
you got to be like listen you know i
can't i can't
hang out with you you're crazy trashing
my dad you're throwing appetizers around
the room
okay i will have dinner with you again
when you can show to me that you can act
like an adult
and you just lay the ground rules this
is how it's going to be we're meeting at
restaurants and you're going to behave
like an adult and you are not going to
trash
my father okay we're going to sit here
we're going to talk about the weather
and what's going on in our lives right
now we're not talking about the past
anymore
that's that's what i need from you if
you can't give me that then
i'm not going to the olive garden
there you go sir i hope that works for
you all right relationship advice
i'm pregnant oh geez
okay hey mr bill i'm a 21 year old
pregnant girl who lives in [ __ ] town
illinois
i moved here a little over a year ago to
be with my boyfriend who i met on
match.com
this is your prince you meet him on
match.match.com led you to [ __ ] town
illinois
there's a [ __ ] one for everybody do
not go on match.com
those stupid commercials they show
everybody happy uh everybody playing
frisbee
women jumping in the guy's arms now you
see some 20 year old girl got knocked up
by some [ __ ] in [ __ ] [ __ ] town
illinois i don't think so
hey sweetheart you know what you're
already a great person because you let
us know what happens at match.com
um everything was great at first then i
realized how much i [ __ ] hate this
place
this town is such a [ __ ] and that
includes the people in it
i've been telling him that and i'm
unhappy for at least six months but he
doesn't seem to care
also you don't really have a problem
with him no great now i have a slander
case with [ __ ] match.com
he said now i'm pregnant with his child
and have the opportunity to move to
arizona to be with my parents
i told him that i'm going to go but he
said that he would absolutely
absolutely would not follow me there he
said he loves this place because it has
a lot of outdoor activities
and he loves his job this is not his
hometown
he makes nine dollars an hour being a
bicycle mechanic
i told him there are bike shops all
around the country
and he can find another [ __ ] job
especially since he is former military
he doesn't care he's a stubborn ass what
the [ __ ] do i do
this place has turned me into a
depressed [ __ ] and i hate myself for it
and i don't want to bring the baby into
that kind of a world
hopefully you can shed some wisdom on
this for me i don't know this is a rough
one so you're basically
going to move to where you want to live
and then he's going to become
you that's what i'm worried about
do you have some sort of job
opportunities in arizona
um because you know
along with having bike shops all around
the country they also have outdoors
you can go outdoors anywhere in the
country that's one of the greatest
things about the united states in russia
they can't go outdoors wherever they go
you
know you get sent to siberian [ __ ] you
are [ __ ] indoors
all right
getting [ __ ] raped in the ass and all
you can feel is somebody's mittens on
your hips
oh that's one of the [ __ ] most evil
jokes i've ever made
um all right
what am i talking about what do you do
uh sweetheart i don't know
if the guy's [ __ ] that level of
stubborn
i i i honestly you know what i i you
stump me
i know you're [ __ ] punching your
[ __ ] ipod right now whatever you
listen to the song what do you
what all right what would i do if i was
a pregnant lady
um well here's a question how do you
feel about this guy
do you love this guy is this the guy
you're gonna marry
um if that's the deal then
i don't know you gotta try and work
something out because you guys are
together and you gotta do you got to try
and do what's best for the kid
but if this guy isn't the guy then i
don't know what to tell you there either
here's some great advice don't get
[ __ ] pregnant by your boyfriend
at 21. i mean i don't know what to tell
you here you really you know what you
really painted yourself into a corner
i think what you have to do is you have
to you got to man up
and make a decision here you have to
make a decision what's best for your
baby
because now you're in this situation i i
know a baby needs a mom and a dad
but if you guys don't really love each
other whether you live in arizona you
live in illinois it's eventually gonna
[ __ ] blow up
so i would just at this point you're
having a baby so your needs are out the
window
it's got to be about the kid which you
did mention in there so i guess
it took me a second to try to figure
this one out i i guess if i was in your
situation i would do
what was best for the baby so whatever
that answer is i would go with that
all right but i don't think that that's
just a
uh a one-sided talk like you really have
to sit down
with uh with your boyfriend there
and try and together figure out what's
best for the kid
and then i would do that alrighty
i hope that helped you out all right
this is a long podcast today um
is this the last this is the last one
all right hang in there everybody
advice for a big presentation hi bill i
saw you special on netflix and i laughed
my face off a few days later i started a
new job
at the sort of place where my co-workers
don't really speak to each other
during work hours you can hear the
wiring you can hear the whirring of the
fan overhead and desk drawers being open
and shut jesus christ
so thank christ for your podcast what a
relief thank you for making my day all
right
i'm presenting at ted at a tedx event
is that like ted.com where all those
eggheads talk about robots and scuba
diving in like a wheelchair
um and i'm wondering what sort of tips
you might have for speaking to large
crowds
try to make them laugh off the top or
save it until i'm further into the
speech
or what you poke fun about bringing a
joke full circle at the end of the set
is that lame
i do this where whenever i write
something
i can't read it once it's published
because it all sounds so cheesy to me oh
if you write it down because you're in
your head
okay i see what you mean he says like i
end up hating what i just put out there
i just want to cringe every time i think
about my speech you know what do you
think
i think you have the classic mentality
of the performer
you want to be in front of everybody you
have self-hatred
and you want the crowd to clap and be
like no but seriously you're a good guy
um i would say this um
just talk to him like you're talking to
your buddies in a bar
that's what i would do i would if if you
don't like what you wrote down
what i would do is i would have talking
points in front of me like i'm starting
with this point and then talk off the
top of your head
if you're good at this by the way all
right now this is one of your first
times doing this you're going to be a
little nervous
it might be good to have something a
little more prepared but
if you're good at you know talking in
front of people i would just have bullet
points
you know like i'm going to talk about
how i ended up in a wheelchair
i'm going to talk about how i used to
love the ocean and then i'm going to
talk about having all of that taken away
from me and then i'm going to talk about
the apparatus and then i'm in the ocean
then i'm going to show them the pictures
and then i'll get all teared up
and then i'm going to wheel myself off
while with one hand while waving
but then i'll be in a circle and then
realize that i'm doing a circular waving
thing in my chair and then i'll just
sort of back up
off the stage you know that's just one
example
but um i think you know what the good
thing is your competition isn't that
stiff there's going to be a bunch of
monotone jackasses
just sitting there going back in 1970
the first
fuel-injected engine you're gonna you
know you're gonna have to go on after
that so it might not be that difficult
so
that's basically what i would do all
right people that's the podcast this
week
thank you for listening please all of
you if you're going to buy something on
amazon.com if you'd like to donate to
this podcast and the wounded warriors
project
please for the love of god go to
billboard.com click on the podcast page
and then click on the amazon link it'll
take you right to amazon
not nothing's going to cost you any more
money it's just amazon
kicks me a little bit of money for
sending traffic their way
and then i take 10 percent of that and i
throw it to the wounded warriors project
and also if you'd like to download my
special you people are all the same you
can do it digitally
you know five dollars or you can buy the
hard copy version that has some extras
on it some tours of cities
um and both of those are available on
the merch
page um that is it go [ __ ] yourselves
have a wonderful week
and i'll uh i'll talk to you next monday
okay bye-bye
you